so what happens
when
the self
is absent
this
the self is absent and there is open
space
[Music]
and
the only thing
that
separates the
open space
that already is
from a contracted sense of self
is these layers of conditioned
assumptions and ideas
many of which are
skillfully put in place
so that we can undergo this journey of
contraction and expansion
so
the only
role
on the spiritual journey
is to
look
at what might be
my contractions
what might be my layers of assumptions
and ideas
that are preventing me
from feeling
absent
like Consciousness or mind is just open
space
without a sense of self without a sense
of others without a sense of lack
just pure wholeness itself
just pure unconditional love
for the whole exploration
and many of those
conditioned layers
our con tracts
that we created for ourselves
are
defended
quite heavily
by
these
Fortress Towers
just shooting down
self-inquiry
[Music]
foreign
things like
psychedelics are so powerful
because they
take those rigid
conditioned layers
and they
suspend them
into
open space
and that's called a glimpse
the absence
of self
but it doesn't stay
and so the role
of the spiritual Seeker
is to relentlessly
decondition those assumed layers
back
into
source
into open space
into love
and that is why it's said
die before you die
and know that there is no death